hi i have a foolproof strategy that
literally can't go wrong
ever i have put a re-freezable ice pack
underneath my laptop to keep it cool
during this game because apparently
being in this pantry
it gets really warm and my laptop can't
breathe
so i'm letting it breathe cool
refreshing ice
which is definitely gonna work out
perfectly and nothing is gonna go wrong
okay
let's get into this game let's get into
this guys we got a laptop treat let's
get into this
two hound wolf squad the sweep of the
factory is complete
no proof of any connection with the
organization guess this just wasn't our
lucky day
i did manage to get my hands on a number
of documents disclosing some of
miranda's experiments
which support our previous theories she
seems to have infected herself with the
muta my seat
which has granted her a number of
abilities including mimicry
she can control her cells and transform
herself to look like anyone or anything
she disguised herself as mia and
infiltrated the winters as home
her objective was clearly to kidnap rose
maybe she thought she could control rose
easier if she looked like her mom
when we attacked it put a little damper
on her plants if she mimicked
a corpse
she then revived herself in the
transport truck killed everyone on board
and took off with rose
things didn't go the way she originally
planned but in the end she still got
what she wanted
until now it's time to rendezvous and
blow this place sky high
this might turn into a fight with
eisenberg but i think i found something
useful
he left one of his little toys laying
around and it's even made of a metal
polymer composite
which he can't control time to turn the
tables okay
you know that don't make too much sense
but i ain't going to complain about it
i'm on a dru why why is it such a long
hold hang on there must be something in
here that's useful
um yeah okay you in here buddy
hey chris did you see a big dude like
that's selling some stuff or is that
just me
this is in my head that's probably just
me
by going crazy okay well that's
everything uh i guess i'm gonna go for
it
whatever it is i mean good thing the big
dude cleared out because there wouldn't
be enough for two of us also good thing
he cleared out because
chris just shot an rpg into it and blew
him to pieces
metal polymer composite huh time to
fight fire with fire
okay well holy [ __ ]
okay all right you know what i'm coming
rose
i'm coming rose i'm coming
[Laughter]
okay this is kind of dope okay this is
kind of dope
this is dope my dudes oh
my god
wow i love this i love this
i love this i love this
this is the greatest day of my life man
that's a long reload on that thing
okay so i can only use that when i
really need it what
what keeps clunk a lunken is that my fat
ass dragon on the back of it
whoa oh yeah give me a battlefield
oh yeah give me a battlefield oh
yeah you're like a goddamn cockroach
yeah i sure am yeah
pretty sure
yeah it doesn't seem like that's gonna
go so good for you
man
i missed
ah what do you do i missed it oh god ow
you need more what bullets i got that
for you buddy whoa
i see your weakness
oh yeah that's the power i'm talking
about baby
you want to see more of my fatherly love
no no you seem to be exploding all over
the place
don't call it your steel glory man never
call it your steel glory
i really don't like that oh yeah
oh yeah
20 years
how how would you do that
um it seems to be going really well for
me
oh something's happening
what am i doing am i doing something
okay i'm doing something
[Music]
yeah the boulder
i love it i love it man i'm not very
fast don't die like the world's watching
die what am i hitting here here we go
okay what am i hitting it's hopeless
right flashing blood
will never win against me this is
[Music]
i'm not sure where i'm supposed to hit
but i seem to be hitting something
i don't know am i doing it
i'm barely i'm doing it
i i'm sorry i didn't know that was your
oh
no uh
oh oh oh
okay
well i know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna pretend like i push that
[Music]
button
um
oh wow
mia alpha ethan
i heard explosions what the hell
happened i dealt with heisenberg
now i'm gonna find miranda and get rose
back not without me
it's too dangerous right there you hear
me
ethan rose ethan
ethan respond yeah this is definitely
real
our child she's so important isn't she
she's everything to me
and mine to me with heisenberg on
you've lost your lead what are you going
to do
i don't know but i'm saving rose you'd
never know
do you even when i took mia's place in
your home
poor ethan who are you where's rose
okay hey hi
enough
remember evelyn and her power over them
all
rose is her successor no
rose is evelyn's true complete
[ __ ] you you crazy [ __ ]
calm yourself rose will be saved
the mega my seat catalogs all of us
however she will be reborn as
my daughter she's my child not yours
where are you show yourself why did rose
come to be
was it because of her parents and you
are truly a special case
but i've learned all i can for you
your worth as a lab rat has run out
miranda you coward come on and face me
oh ow hey wait a minute
your death will come quick i don't know
if i can make my
seats records
hey i need that i think anyway i will
make sure to sample your blood for later
i'm gonna just goose real quick
one stone the ceremony will be complete
and i will become her true mother
bound for eternity and blood okay it was
a little weird
okay well i i i would like to have that
back
i really liked it okay well yes that's
it for me then guys good game everyone
we really tried
the dreams really can come true
i can't wait to see my true child again
all right cool um good game i really
liked it uh ending was a bit abrupt but
you know
sometimes these things just uh turn out
that way
and you know say la vie
anyway nine out of ten i'll give it that
good stuff
um i've confirmed the death of ethan
winters oh [ __ ]
i wasn't able to retrieve the body but
i've recorded evidence
share your screen and i'll go over the
situation
my team and i were careless yesterday
we took down the transformed miranda but
we didn't kill her
who knew she could fake being a corpse
since miranda could have infected ethan
i forcefully took him
and rose with us
but the vehicle they were riding in was
attacked
when i got to the wreck ethan and rose
were gone
the last time i was able to contact
ethan
i heard miranda's voice
she murdered him and she is not
gonna get away with it
god damn it when does it end
that sir the mission
all of it three years trying to put this
thing in the ground
three years too long
such a badass such [ __ ] badass
goddammit so tough
so [ __ ] tough i smoke a cigarette in
one single puff
all the way down
i'm guessing i play chris time to go
punch some rocks
hey can you help all right so bsaa got
here already
um i didn't waste any time mission
adjustment
no it doesn't change anything terminate
miranda
and rescue rose that's the mission
and failure's not an option let's have
some fun people like old times
move out how many times everyone
everyone you have to say
just like old times no matter what
military mission i want to know what's
always just like
what he's doing here find out what you
can roger that i'm on it
am i playing chris in a while since we
fought together captain
oh look at all my whoa now that's a
knife
now that's a knife let's put that what
is that what is that
target locator
bro okay you know what i'm i'm gonna put
it here
i love this when was it last the desert
doing nothing but recon's gotten me out
of shape but thanks to your recon we
know miranda's plan
couldn't quite believe it when i heard
you turn yourself in the mia though
taking five shots to their heads nothing
to sneeze at either
spooky yeah spooky
also why were you so far away when all
this went down you think you would have
been closer because you know you gave me
the big machine that i
uh
okay cool what am i looking at
yeah they're awfully close to that
hey get out of here it looks pretty
rough down there oh that's it that's all
it took
okay now reaching the objective first
we're gonna have to take that thing out
i've got your back boss let's get to
work okay cool
everyone watch for hostile bio weapons
yeah okay roger
i think that's pretty much made contact
oh wow oh it's great to have bullets oh
it's nice to have bullets
oh yes please yes please yes please
i bet even my knife's better and think
of what i could have done with this
i think what i could have done with any
assistance from these guys
bsa craft spotted two guards
i could take them don't get cocky
what is the bsaa oh this is where the
the person died i guess
let's go yeah it's safe i'll just walk
through here this is fine they're not
going to pierce me through my heart or
nothing
[Music]
except for me i'm too badass to do that
i'm chris redfield i don't need that
missed me [ __ ] oh you mean you hit me
but it didn't hurt me [ __ ]
yeah that's right that's what i thought
you better stay down pretty tough i
punch rocks all the time
it's my workout and my meals anybody
want to dance
it's me i'm at the location
roger tundra here leaving some supplies
in one of the houses
thanks which house whoa holy crap i have
night vision
well that's pretty cool um which house
you're not gonna say which one are you
you're not gonna tell me which one all
right cool
200 to the point what do you mean 200 to
the point what does that mean
200 what to the point 200 bullets to
where you're pointing
that's easy you guys are making it easy
on me
[Applause]
you gonna do anything you're just gonna
be up there okay cool wow hey nice perch
man this really is really oh
now one second one second one second one
second hey
hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on i know you don't hey wait wait
whoa
easy easy
easy
man this is dope as hell
when do i get to play the game again
with just with this weapon the whole
time
because this is pretty cool not gonna
lie
this is me and i'm having a
good time
nice perch i don't know why they keep
doing that expecting something to happen
one thing that's gonna happen is they
fall over and die
okay good job
well why is your mom seeing this
shouldn't this be extremely excessively
classified or something
how do i get over there there's
something over there in the house over
there how do i get over there
how do i get over there there's got to
be a way
what if i use a flash grenade on the
fire would that do it that that would do
it
it did not do it
man these guys suck hi again i thought i
cleared out this area i think it just
keeps coming back but that's okay
reach the target location damn this is
big
the hell is that supposed to be marking
the target
a mark in the dark yeah here's the
marked target the target has been marked
here's the mark on the target
can you do another one can you can you
do it now
just a minute i mean i don't know how
you didn't see that it was kind of like
really big a swarm you say
nice hey nice perch
right nah
let's not do what hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey
hey
hang on well i gotta paint my target i'm
gonna paint a target here you guys hush
up i gotta paint this target
i'm gonna paint this target
i'm reloading reloading what
what are you even shooting
how about one of these oh yo
okay that was pretty effective hey
what's up bud
you survived that well that's too bad
next how about the same place you just
pointed
that'd be pretty cool how about you do
that it's kind of like
still the same because i'm gonna
flashbang and that should give me just
enough time to
get this pointy thing going you guys are
engaging
you'll never he's freaking idiots these
freaking have no idea
oh [ __ ] was i in the right spot
i don't know if i hit the right spot i
did good
well that was good for me and good for
whatever the hell we were doing here and
wherever the hell that came from
hey a hole in the ground all right well
mission accomplished boys let's all go
home
you could just like keep shooting at
everything
it seems like bullets are surprisingly
effective in this uh
universe so you could just like keep
shooting
pretty sure oh am i supposed to go in
the hole in the ground i found a way
down
i'm going in the rest of you stay back
why why why
i compared the mold at the village with
the sample from the bakers and
there's no sign of the genome editing we
saw in the e-series
the stuff originated here
okay cool i'm gonna pretend like i know
what all that means
ooh this looks fun i love the growling
hi oh you're
use it
yeah well you know i've probably taken
off bigger guys than you so i don't
think this is actually too big a deal
what are you doing don't do it don't do
it that's what i thought
okay well you if that's not gonna do
anything then we're gonna have a problem
here
good thing i'm super tough
all right
good i'll signal with the volcano
oh nice
come on come on come on there's nothing
nothing
okay well maybe that's something
oh yeah targeted goose
how about a flashbang and then another
one of these
and three two one kabob you up there
you looking down on me
hold your horses whose horses are you
talking about
oh never mind we're good i guess we did
it oh i'll keep going
the rest of you stay above them as could
this possibly be oh it's too big to use
no this is chris redfield chris redfield
the reddest field oh he could punch that
hammer in the next century
no well fine fine if you're gonna be
that way
i'll just keep going on the ground fake
mia where's the real one
i doubt she saw any further use for her
i don't get any of this how did miranda
even know rose exists
the moldy little bird told her maybe we
can figure that out later
focus on the plan yeah focus on the plan
guys what the hell ooh
i don't like this plan it's the mega
mice oh it's a baby
oh it's a baby it's a cure oh god it's a
movie you care oh guys a big baby
well that's weird out for the squad i've
located the mega my seat
so now we can end this mess after all
about damn time
nice and two explosives aren't
there's enough there to blow the whole
village sky high let's get out of here
and blow the damn place
not before i end miranda i'm not taking
any more chances
i'm going in okay good standing by yeah
no one else doing anything i got this
guys
hey miranda hey listen
it's been real cool hunting you for
three years but i really want you to
like be not doing what you're doing
you know the breathing thing can you not
do that that'd be really cool if you
could do that
okay cool i mean if you could not do
that this must be miranda's lab
oh hi oh okay well that's interesting
ooh salvator moreo cat affinity low
brain functions surprisingly low the
caddo has caused drastic changes on
internal organs
transforming them into organs similar to
fish like gills in a swim bladder
another subject with a regular cell
division causing him to transform into a
giant fish
the subject is unable to control the
transformation too many defects
an unfit vessel for eva okay
a little harsh but okay ooh
alcina dimitrescu cadu affinity
most favorable brain functions normal
regeneration rate is incredibly fast
the subject can heal any external wounds
within seconds
and grow her nails into claws and mere
moments rapid regeneration also means an
increased body size
note due to a hereditary blood disease
the subject must ingest human flesh and
blood
on a regular basis to maintain
regeneration properties
i suspect that if the subject's
regeneration is not properly
balanced then she may mutate
uncontrollably
an unfit vessel for eva that's because
no
alcina dimitrescu would ever be a vessel
for someone
so unworthy as an eva already perfect is
what you were trying to say
already the pinnacle of evolution
literally could do no better so why
would you even need a vessel forever
i think that was in the subtext i read
between the lines a lot you know
very intelligent like that carl
eisenberg incredibly favorable brain
function normal has electric organs
similar to the electric ray
narcae japonica these electric organs
are connected to the subject's nervous
system can therefore pass and control
electricity throughout the body allowing
control of magnetic fields which is used
to move metal
splendid specimen but still an unfit
vessel for eva
splendid splendid
truly splendid donna beneviento
favorable normal although severe mental
illness physically she is no different
from a regular human however she can
secrete
a signal producing substance which
controls plants infected by the mutabist
when a humans absorb the pollen from a
particular flower she can you cause him
to have hallucinations however she is
mentally underdeveloped and has divided
her tattoo among her dolls in order to
control them from a distance an unfit
vessel for eva this one i i didn't even
understand oh
hi ooh hey what's up bud
could do huh
the bio weapons interesting oh that's
fun
well this is all great love me a lab are
those
those flying brooms is that what you got
there
hmm that's interesting
on explore dear miranda my deepest
apologies for not meeting you in person
i would love nothing more than to visit
your quaint village once more however i
am incredibly busy
then again i suppose for such an
immortal woman such as yourself
you no longer remember this poor
half-dead medical student in the snow
i have always cherished the revelations
i came to 15 years ago when i stayed in
your village i was inspired by your
research to think
one could transform a human by infecting
them with an organism positively
visionary
i knew that with the knowledge i could
achieve my own vision for the next step
in human evolution
even after two world wars and humanity
on the cusp of another
my conviction never wavered i realized
however that through many nights the
intellectual talks you and i
shared that your conviction different
for mine you hope to bring back a single
dead person
well i aim to change the world your
experiments on the mold would not have
aided me in my endeavor to cheese and
exponential infection
i thought a virus would be more
effective this is why my dear i had to
leave you
i still regret never telling you goodbye
my apologies for reminiscing
i actually have news that i thought
might please you i found the key to
evolution
the progenitor a virus found in africa i
plan to start a company with friends and
colleagues dedicate the to the viruses
research
i will call it umbrella just like the
symbol in the cave that we spoke about
i am one step closer to making my vision
a reality
i hope you will be able to achieve your
goal someday too you taught me so much
and for that i will be forever in your
debt
sincerely your lifelong student oswell e
spencer
spencer here no way
well apparently yes way apparently
absolutely yes way
these lovebirds with their horrible
world-ending
diseases oh so
lovely good stuff good good stuff
good great stuff actually incredible
stuff the best stuff
is one what what one might say anywho
more hey who are you zeva raleigh
my eva it has been 100 years since i
lost you to the spanish flu
not so powerless back then but now now i
can bring you back to life from the mega
my seat
oopsies i had to test a new vessel's
regenerative abilities
i took her apart and revived her in the
mega my seed regulator the giants
chalice
all that's left is the merger with the
mega mystery the ceremony can finally
begin
after i lost you i was so stricken with
grief that i wandered into a cave to die
i so wanted to be with you again and
that's when i found
the megami scene completely by accident
when i touched the black substance my
mind was overcome with knowledge
the megamycin breaks down and absorbs
the consciousness of those who have
perished i knew that if your
consciousness was in there too
then there would be a way to bring you
back i just need the right vessel
so how does it do the the consciousness
thing when i returned to the village i
implanted the villagers with mold from
the mega my seat
that way i could control them experiment
on them i have experimented on hundreds
of people just to find you the perfect
vessel
i even tried to increase the efficiency
of finding a vessel by creating a
parasite i called kadu
yet none of my experience came to
fruition
there were some like alcena who were
close to being perfect
close [ __ ] shut up but most turned into
lichens
i was once approached by an organization
who said they would assist me
i gave them some of the mold in your dna
but all they created was another defect
evelyn and again not a complete failure
i learned of rose thanks to them and i
knew she would be the perfect vessel
there was some interference but i was
able to verify her suitability
now my research is finally complete eva
i have waited too long to see you again
well that's
real nice and all that that's really
sweet
uh very nice why do these people look
familiar
what's with that dude's head hello hi
who are you
okay cool well anyway time to go
kill mobber maramba oh wait no don't
tell me that was
i thought oh hi
me your hands i'm bryce this is alpha
where is miranda right now
still the ceremony whatever she's doing
she's staying put
god damn it really is you
i'm glad you saved me why are you here
i was caught in houston experiments
wait did you say mia mia winters in the
flesh
what's the situation up there kind of a
war going on nothing we can't handle
don't get distracted stick to the
mission i'm headed to the ceremony site
i thought that was
a secret not where i was supposed to go
you can't leave me here
you promised damn it you said that you
would keep us safe
we did everything that you asked we
moved over here everything
and i didn't care so long as we were
together
so you tell me where is my husband
where is my daughter nathan is
he's gone
i couldn't save him but i can save rose
come on it's not safe here after all
what do you mean he's gone
he's dead
i'm sorry mia but we have to leave we
have to destroy this village
no you're wrong
i tried to keep this a secret but
you don't understand how special he is
oh i'm pretty special all right oh look
how special i am
who's your special boy who's a special
boy
oh ethan who's so special
no where are we oh hey look at that
what's going on
uh-oh well this campus is there
okay hey what's up it's cold yeah
really cold i'm freezing it's [ __ ]
hot in here
we still recording good good good good
hey what's going on hey how you doing
how did i get here
god freeze
just [ __ ] my body
well don't fall in the river okay and
you fall on the river
okay that would be very bad for keeping
warm
you're
[Music]
you're dead
dad i mean
miranda she
no i still have to save bros
wrong it wasn't miranda
you were always dead
what are you saying i can still
see miranda didn't kill you
you mean you didn't think it was weird
no matter
how much you got hurt
remember
three years ago the baker house
[Music]
you were murdered by jack
you died there three years ago
that's that's it's awesome no way
you shouldn't even be able to walk
around
[Music]
quit messing with my head
you shouldn't be walking
screw you
i
did all that
[Music]
yeah all right
[Music]
[Music]
how do you get it your whole body
is nothing but mold
you can't ever see your family again
[Music]
family
save my daughter
you're already dead
[Laughter]
[Music]
dead
super saiyan ascension yeah well how did
i still make a baby
made a fungus baby at least my mold
balls still work i guess i knew
something was wrong with that baby
i could tell that baby was not right not
right in the
mold you know what i mean something
right about that baby
who cares who cares if i'm mold not me
damn it what's being alive screw that
hear that nonsense oh where's
he awakes hey
where am i my carriage ethan you were
having
a nightmare ah
duke your battle with heisenberg was a
sight to see
hmm to think miranda would show herself
how long have i been out not long till
dawg
duke i need a favor
yeah take me to miranda i assumed as
much and i'm already on the way
this guy's good this guy's good we
should arrive shortly this guy's really
good
thank you but ethan
are you sure of this your body is well
falling apart
yes foolish of me to ask
speaking of foolish questions who or
what are you
even i can't quite answer that
we're here quite poignant
i owe you one mr winters
i'm afraid you can't return to your old
world any longer
are you ready
yeah i have to be
yeah hell yeah hell yeah i have to be
oh yeah i gotta go i gotta go i gotta go
i gotta go save i gotta go i gotta i
gotta get out of here all this what is
all this nonsense
there's all this nonsense just lying
around hey bud listen to this before i
go
oreo has everything you need for your
decisive battle
my decision well i'm gonna sell this and
i'm gonna sell this and i'm never gonna
sell that and i am gonna sell this
okay how did i get that from chris well
that's suspicious
that's awfully suspicious oh the
assemblage of life
and machine i can feel lord heisenberg's
essence through it creepy
what a weird thing to say what a bizarre
thing to say that's really weird hmm
great never say anything like that ever
again
all right good oh
give me some of this slaughtering drones
oh what is this
long barrel hell yeah wait the v61 is
that
oh long barrel
hell yeah okay and with that yes
please be well i know thanks
i will but but i'll be back because i'm
probably gonna do a little more anyway
so the climactic ending of this game is
coming up in the next episode and if i
end it too early in the episode we're
just gonna have to play some of the
bonus modes that i know is gonna be
there
which should be very fun but thank you
everybody so much for watching
i'm gonna step out of this hot hot room
i'm gonna give my laptop a break but
thank you
check out more videos that i've done in
the suggested videos over there are
linked in the description
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]
you